[Music]
behind us the battle is raging on here
on the set of Ironman I do earplugs I
don't want to I don't want to not be
able to hear it when someone says you're
on fire face
why do you relate to him I think because
there's there's an element of him having
to come to terms with the repercussions
of his actions and also I love America
so much and I think he's someone who who
is providing these arms and weapons for
America and then really gets to to look
at the flip side of that and really see
what happens when people are killed and
they're going off and being used my turn
I also figured if I was ever gonna do
one of these kinds of movies this genre
that this would be a good time to do it
before I'm too old and can't get in
shape particularly if we wind up doing
more than one I am Iron Man guy and also
look I mean he didn't get bit by a
spider and he doesn't have some creepy
thing about bats he's a guy who builds
creates and vents and puts his own ass
on the line with everything he does I
just pay for everything and design
everything and make everyone look cooler